if you need to drink in order to be able
to enjoy your night out you're choosing
the wrong nights out what you're saying
is that the experience that you're going
on is so bad that you have to
anesthetize yourself you have to numb
yourself to the experience it's like
saying I'm gonna go stick needles
through the skin on the back of my hand
but I'll take some painkillers so it
doesn't hurt so much yeah as you grow up
you start to do different sorts of
events you'll go for dinner more you'll
go to quieter venues you'll go to
somewhere where there's a live music
where you can have a conversation that
sort of enjoyment is facilitated more by
being sober so I wonder whether it's a
byproduct of the kind of events that
young people typically attend when
you're in an environment where everybody
else is drunk when you're sober and
you're just looking at people oh
heavy I feel like if I'm in an
environment where everybody's drunk I
almost need to be drunk just to feel